throw your luggage in the river and meet
a mentally unstable man in his rental
boat because we have an absolutely
insane episode of the changeling which
means all new theories and Mysteries to
solve for those of you who are new to my
videos this is not a recap but a deep
dive into the biggest theories Mysteries
and clues the show has to offer if you
haven't checked out my episodes one to
three video be sure to do that I'll
leave a link to it in the description
below keep in mind I have not read the
book the show is based on so there will
be no spoilers just sleuthing and as
always I encourage you to write your own
theories in the comments below now
follow me
like And subscribe our first mystery
this episode comes from Young Lillian
dragging a piece of red luggage but what
I'm really interested in is her face it
looks like she was dating Chris Brown my
mind immediately goes to her husband or
perhaps now ex-husband Brian West but we
can't be a hundred percent sure remember
that it was Lillian who asked for a
divorce shortly after the birth of
Apollo which may suggest Brian was
abusive however Lillian never mentions
his abuse if there was any at all I'm
gonna go out on a limb here and think
that Brian being an abuser is a red
herring it's also really strange that
Apollo finds himself at the same
location decades later is there
something in that luggage that he is
connected to or perhaps is calling to
him obviously this luggage is quite
important since it's featured both at
the beginning of the episode the end and
in the intro credits we just don't have
enough information yet as to what's
inside for all I know it could be
Apollo's twin baby sister in my episodes
one to three video I brought up that an
ancient mythology Apollo had a twin
sister named Artemis it's crazy but let
me know what you think the writers here
made a conscious decision to end the
episode with older Lillian wearing the
same exact outfit she wore when she
dropped the luggage decades ago it
doesn't look like she's going into that
water but it's clear they want us to see
the importance of this luggage its
location and the connection between
younger and older Lillian red was also
an interesting choice for the luggage's
color it being the color of the Strand
given to Emma in South America last
episode we were introduced to William
wheeler who attended Apollo Survivor
group where he secretly filmed a woman
with a connection to the wise ones
there's a lot going on with this guy and
it's tough to decipher if what he's
saying is true or if he's manipulating
Apollo William wants to buy Apollo
signed copy of To Kill a Mockingbird
which he says is an attempt to win back
his wife Greta we never meet Greta so we
can't be sure if William is just using
this as a ploy to get closer to Apollo a
man he'll later say is key in making
sure everyone on the island survives at
the beginning of the episode Patrice
shows Apollo a Brian cogwa fan page with
members posting absolutely vile posts
about Apollo and Emma of note is this
guy named kindergarten who comes up
several times in the episode take a look
at his Avatar this weird emblem thing
here if I'm not mistaken it looks
strikingly similar to the necklace that
falls off William when he's beaten by
Cal near the end of the episode on their
way to the island William asks if Apollo
told anyone where he's going because
someone on the fan page said stay safe
on them open Waters the only person
Apollo told was Patrice but I'm gonna
take a guess that this is a fake account
created by William to manipulate Apollo
the kindergarten friend more page which
is this world's equivalent of Facebook
includes some really interesting Clues
the account says this person is from
Norway and they were born July 5th 1825
which is the same date the sale dealers
from Norway that we saw in episode 1
sailed to America and guess who says
they grew up in Norway learning to sail
on boats it's William his posts are
mainly about eating people especially
babies which aligns with what fairies do
in the book to the waters in the wild in
my last video I theorized that there
could be some sort of war between
fairies and witches if this is the case
it could mean that William here is a
fairy it's kind of funny that William
served in the Air Force and fairies can
fly and did any of you think it's super
odd that after nearly getting beaten to
death he Springs up almost like it
didn't affect him and even makes a joke
at least I got my glasses back like I'd
barely be able to move after this
William also talks about an extensive
network of people beyond the NYPD and
Feds that can be mobilized to find Emma
it was this group that was able to
obtain CCTV footage of Emma and find her
on an island in the East River this does
not seem like a red-of-the-mill keyboard
detectives William was implying near the
end of the episode it's reveal that
William knew about Apollo and Brian long
ago hearing the story of Brian's birth
on the A train he became obsessed with
Apollo because Apollo had that perfect
life that he never had according to him
his wife Greta listened to Cal and it's
heavily implied killed one of their
daughters and ran off now William wants
Apollo to talk to Greta and explain to
her that William forgives her and wants
to be a family again cal said that Greta
will be brought to the island for when
they kill William so maybe there's
something Apollo can say to get them out
of this situation Cal talks about Apollo
first having to quote eat his Humble Pie
which implies that he will need to
understand how not as important or
special he is but its meaning here is
purposely vague according to William if
he doesn't eat his pie everyone on the
island will die could it mean if he
doesn't get out of here something bad
will happen to the island maybe this is
connected to William's phone which the
guards say they found William waving it
toward the shore with the light on
William must be communicating with
someone else remember he did say he has
lots of connections and resources or the
everyone will die statement can be
interpreted in a metaway that by eating
this so-called pie it ends Apollo's
story thus the characters and everyone
in it metaphorically dies because the
story is over the narrator at the
beginning of the episode states that
quote each tale told upon the Water
informs the next story and the next
although briefly mentioned is Apollo
talking to Emma's sister about her third
wish something we have yet to uncover
while we may never find out what this
Third Wish really is some have argued
that it was for a life of adventure or
to become a witch sorceress the most
compelling argument comes from this
brief line of dialogue from the old
Washerwoman herself it was Teflon TV
that pointed this out check out his
channel he does videos on the changeling
too three wishes for your life
essentially stating that in exchange for
three wishes the old woman will
literally take Emma's life by swapping
bodies so when Apollo broke the string
it began the process of this body Swap
this would also explain why Emma's
friend said Emma looked like a sorceress
when she saw that naked photo of her
there is something really off with this
island Williams says he went up and down
this River several times and never found
it so it seems like there's something
about Apollo that allows him access here
as the narrator says there are portals
in this world that we may never know
we've trespassed through maybe they
passed through some sort of portal
William guesses from the abandoned
hospital beds this is North Brothers
Island where Typhoid Mary was kept for
several years and today sits abandoned
as a refuge for waterfowl the island is
inhabited by a group of women William
and Apollo called the wise ones yet none
of the women ever refer to themselves as
such we see a bunch of toys everywhere
suggesting children are near yet we
never see any kids this group is led by
a cow allegedly the same woman Emma had
helper in the plot to kill her child Cal
is short for Callisto and in Greek
mythology Callisto is a follower of
Artemis the twin sister of Apollo in my
last video I suggested Cal could also be
short for Calliope Apollo's mother which
I think could still be a possibility in
the show as crazy as this there may be
multiple cows but seeing as this cow is
also connected to mythology these names
are no coincidence Callisto is
interested in what it takes to protect
our children using the story of Rapunzel
as a metaphor stating no matter what we
do the world always seems to find a way
to force its way in check out this red
string she attaches onto the back of the
Sorceress puppet before it speaks to
Apollo I'm assuming this is not Apollo
string since these two haven't yet met
there's also talk of the Scottish term
glamor essentially a magic spell used to
make one thing look like another
suggesting that Ryan wasn't a baby at
all remember that Emma called it a devil
and not her son but if Brian was an
illusion then who created it
unfortunately Callisto and Apollo are
interrupted before this is answered in
mythology fairies are known to utilize
Illusions such as paying someone in Gold
only for it to turn into leaves later on
could this be some sort of fairy magic
and now for a few miscellaneous things I
noticed that I couldn't quite fit into
the main video the name of William's
rental boat is Child's Play named after
the killer doll movie and the fact both
of their children have been killed
William's boat rental app is called
Rockabye named after the famous child's
lullaby Rock-a-bye Baby more missing
persons posters scattered around the
city and I also love the Added Touch of
Apollo having to walk past children
gleefully playing on a playground I'm
sure I missed a lot but now I turn it
over to you what did you think of
episode 4 of the changeling I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember at least I got
my glasses back
thank you